qu'ils aient 6 ans ou plus de 17 ans ils
ont tous la même passion le breakdance
et d'une manière plus générale ils sont
fans de la culture hip-hop cette
cinquième édition du holtwin a proposé
des battles engagés mais très fair-play
on a l'impression que la breakdance
était démodé mais pas du tout ah non pas
du tout pas du tout au contraire vous
avez vu il y a on a une très très bonne
génération et on a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de chance aujourd'hui mise à part on
s'est décalé délocalisé et du coup on
est venu au gymnase alors qu'on était au
keviève donc et là on voit que tous les
dangers sont venus et on avait près de
70 jeunes inscrits au premier battle au
premier battle 70 jeunes donc c'était
vraiment vraiment costaud pour Lucas
bboy originaire du port le breakdance
est en fait une création influencée par
des cultures différents il y a beaucoup
de créativité c'est toi qui crée ton
mouvement et tu l'amènes comme tu veux
et un mouvement représente danseur du
coup mes mouvements représentent moi on
va voir mes mouvements c'est ah ça c'est
du Lucas c'est pas du je sais pas qui ou
je sais pas quoi c'est du Lucas mais il
y a de l'aspiration quand même oui
l'inspiration beaucoup des arts martiaux
capoeira excellent même du football du
basketball on s'inspire de tout et c'est
ça qui est bien avec le brain dance
c'est tout sport confondus et ça fait un
truc magique pour Nissa bigger le fait
de concourir avec des garçons et face
les différences des fois des
compétitions il y a des moments où c'est
des compétition
S mais pour DJ crazy eyes et DJ d'askill
qui était au platine cet après-midi le
breakdance c'est avant tout de la
musique c'est un DJ qui a inventé le
hip-hop donc tout ça c'est à cause d'un
DJ et tout est parti là le break le
graphe beatmaking la danse même les M6
ça vient de ça aussi ça ça crache pas
mal là ça scratch mais il a pas que ça
ça mixe aussi il y a pas que ça le
scratch c'est bien la technique c'est
bien mais fait danser les gens c'est
mieux aussi seul trois compétiteurs sur
70 ont obtenu leur billet pour assister
à la compétition en métropole la
sélection a été rude pour ce hall to win
5e édition cependant à tous un gros big
up